when Warren Buffett bought Coca-Cola at
whatever price he bought it at what did
he need to do for the next 50 years not
sell it and he talks about his best
investments of his life he said he's
made 12 great Investments if you Pace
that out that's one every five years
there was a five-year period where
Berkshire didn't invest any money they
did no deals for five years most people
don't have that kind of patience they
need activity they need stuff to do
doing stuff doesn't necessarily mean
you're getting close to the goal I think
a lot of times we mistake like activity
for progress and sometimes things just
take time big things take time